j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
cette émission débat de société vous
savez on essaie le plus souvent possible
de prendre du recul de le décaler de
l'actualité du jour il porte sur la
semaine de quatre jours faut-il la
généraliser en France les salariés qui
ont bénéficient sont-ils forcément plus
heureux plus efficaces avant d'en
débattre gros plan sur une entreprise de
la banlieue de Lyon qui a réduit le
temps de travail à 32 heures par semaine
reportage signé Norbert Evangéliste il y
a environ deux ans Mathieu célébrait un
heureux événements et se réjouissait de
la mise en place de la semaine de quatre
jours dans son entreprise le lundi on
arrive au travail le matin on se dit bah
demain soir j'ai déjà un jour de repos
pour soi profiter de la famille soit
soit faire les tâches ménagères aller
dans le jardin etc un vrai bénéfice pour
ce jeune papa soumis aux contraintes
professionnelles de son épouse pour
passer du temps en famille ma femme est
infirmière elle travaille un week-end
sur deux et pour le coup au moins en
général un mercredi sur deux on peut
profiter ensemble de la journée alors
qu'on va pas se voir le weekend
le patron de Mathieu c'est lui Laurent
de la Clergerie est dirigeant et
fondateur de cette société spécialisée
dans la vente de matériel informatique
créé il y a 25 ans son choix de faire
travailler ses salariés en 4 jours le
fruit d'une expérience et d'un
raisonnement d'une logique implacable
on travaille 5 jours le moment on va
faire un break dans sa tête c'est les
vacances si on projette ça sur une
semaine à 4 jours on a un jour dans la
semaine ouvré on peut tout faire on peut
faire tout ce qu'on va décaler on peut
prendre du temps pour soi on peut aussi
prendre les rendez-vous chez les
médecins tous ces trucs qui sont
impossibles à prendre parce qu'on sait
un jour ouvré et puis ben quand on
arrive au week-end on a quasiment tout
fait donc en fait on a un vrai week-end
quatre jours sans perte de salaire mais
surtout répartie sur 32 heures le tout
s'en ralentir la productivité une
équation qu'il était possible de
résoudre à condition d'optimiser les
procédures on va dire qu'on s'organise
autrement il y a peut-être des tâches
qu'on faisait peut-être plus
régulièrement quand on va faire moins
souvent
par exemple des bilans dans mon cas des
analyses de choses peut-être me dire je
vais le faire plus qu'une fois par mois
de les faire une fois par semaine donc
on se dégage du temps comme ça après on
a les réunions aussi on va faire des
réunions plus courtes on va aller plus
droite au but comme on dit entouré de
salariés moins stressés le jeune
dirigeant et parvenu à réduire de moitié
les accidents du travail et
l'absentéisme sans coup supplémentaire
et en augmentant même de 40% son chiffre
d'affaires bref tout va bien et sans
doute trop bien dans une entreprise
qu'on a plus envie de quitter là il y a
un petit mais
en fait sur le turnover on s'est rendu
compte là cette année après les époques
covid on est un petit peu en
décroissance parce que forcément il y a
plus de covid
et ben on a quelques réflexions du type
mais je vais pas pouvoir évoluer dans
cette boîte
parce qu'en fait on Manager ne va jamais
partir puisqu'il est super bien
et effectivement on est dans cette
situation où les gens sont tellement
bien il y a pas la possibilité de
travailler 4 jours ailleurs ça changera
un petit peu les choses et du coup plus
personne a envie de bouger et certains
ont le sentiment que ça peut les limiter
dans leur capacité de travail ils ont
pas pour autant envie de partir mais
justement ça crée une frustration la
moitié des prêts de 1000 employés de la
société à vous privilégier l'intérêt du
travail dans leur carrière mais la
plupart redoutent s'il le fallait de
devoir retourner travailler 5 jours par
semaine
impeccable faut-il généraliser la
semaine de quatre jours en France on en
débat tout de suite avec Pierre
Larrouture ou bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes député européen nouvelle donne
Marie Lacroix bonjour ce soir bienvenue
vous êtes docteur en neurosciences
cofondatrice de code x agence de
conseils d'entreprise pour y améliorer
la qualité de vie en s'appuyant sur les
neurosciences et la gaillard bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes directeur du
département analysé prévisions de l'OFCE
et Mathieu croissanto est évidemment
restez à mes côtés un premier chiffre
selon le ministère du Travail environ 10
000 salariés sont concernés aujourd'hui
en France par la semaine de quatre jours
est-ce que c'est un chiffre en
augmentation puis à la retourne oui je
pense passer à quelques années on en
parlait pas du tout les 35 heures
avaient tué le débat et c'était un sujet
vraiment complètement tabou et puis il y
a deux ans quand LDLC s'est lancé
c'était vraiment les premiers on les
voit ils sont fous et puis au bout d'un
an ils ont dit l'expérience est très
intéressante ça marche très bien et
toutes les semaines on l'entend des
dizaines d'entreprises qui commencent à
expérimenter les quatre jours simplement
ça pourrait aller encore plus vite s'il
y avait des aides parce qu'il y a de la
question est-ce qu'on peut avoir des
embauches il y a des entreprises qui
peuvent passer à quatre jours sans créer
d'emploi et donc elles n'ont pas besoin
d'aide il y en a pour qui si on veut pas
augmenter le stress il faudrait créer
des emplois donc il faudrait qu'il y a
une aide qui existait pas non très
longtemps ce qu'on appelait la loi de
Robien qui disait quand l'entreprise
passe à 4 jours 32 heures si elle crée
des emplois elle arrête de payer les
cotisations en chômage donc il y a tous
ceux et celles qui sont passés à 4 jours
depuis le covid en gros le covid a
vraiment servi de catalyseur et puis
vous souvenez qu'il y avait eu 400
entreprises Mamie Nova Fleury Michon
tout ça c'est des entreprises ou tous
les salariés soient étaient passés à 32
heures dans les années 90 ou le bilan
était excellent déjà alors on va voir
effectivement peut-être se rendre compte
qu'il y a plusieurs semaines de quatre
jours il y a différents modèles et on va
rentrer dans le détail pour bien
comprendre mais tiens un sondage qui a
été publié par Le œuf Post qui nous dit
75% des Français ils sont favorables à
la semaine de quatre jours mais alors
quand on leur propose Marie Lacroix par
exemple dans j'ai vu ça dans dans
certains services publics sont pas
forcément volontaires oui alors donc ça
c'est parce qu'on accompagne notamment
la CNAV sur le expérimentation du
passage à la semaine
en quatre jours donc c'est pas la
semaine forcément deux quatre jours avec
réduction de travail du temps de travail
mais c'est bien la semaine en quatre
jours donc on fait le même temps de
travail mais en même temps quatre jours
et donc là effectivement finalement on
voit bien comment les contraintes
personnelles fait que on n'a pas
forcément envie d'avoir des journées
plus longues pour gagner un jour off et
donc effectivement sur l'expérimentation
qui a été proposée donc c'était sur la
base du volontariat finalement sur les
200 300 personnes qui avaient à qui on a
proposé il n'y a qu'une vingtaine qui a
décidé de s'engager dans cette
expérimentation donc effectivement ça
peut-être parce que c'était la semaine
en quatre jours et pas deux quatre jours
est-ce que vous faites cette année cette
année c'est analyse là j'y arrive oui on
voit bien comment les contraintes
personnelles font que voilà on veut pas
rallonger la durée du travail sur notre
semaine parce que voilà contraintes
familiale on peut pas forcément rentrer
tard etc en revanche effectivement sur
d'autres accompagnements qu'on a pu
faire notamment welcome to the qui est
passé à la semaine de 4 jours avec donc
maintien du salaire maintien de
réduction du temps de travail là du
temps de travail à quatre jours au lieu
de 5 et donc là effectivement il y avait
beaucoup plus de volontaires qui
voulaient expérimenter avec les
questionnements que ça pouvait amener
aussi sur la durabilité la faisabilité
de ce passage à la semaine et 4 jours on
va venir écailler pour une entreprise ça
suppose quand même une organisation je
vais je vais dire quelque chose qui est
un peu idiot mais il faut qu'il y a du
monde le vendredi aussi quoi vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
quand vous êtes une entreprise de
service vous êtes obligé d'ouvrir tous
les jours et effectivement une semaine
de quatre jours ça ça marcherait pas à
avoir un jour off ça serait sans doute
un chiffre d'affaires qui chuterait
énormément et donc du coup ça serait pas
rentable et donc on voit bien du côté du
salarié effectivement la semaine si vous
la faites avec 9 heures par rapport par
semaine par jour pardon ça marche pas
parce qu'on sait que la productivité
horaire chute avec la dernière heure
c'est-à-dire que la 9e heure vous êtes
beaucoup moins productive que la 8e donc
vous vous êtes fatigué vous êtes moins
pro donc pour votre entreprise
séparentable et si en plus vous fermez
un jour c'est la catastrophe
effectivement donc ça ne peut pas
marcher comme cela donc quand vous
passez à une semaine de quatre jours et
ben vous faites des binômes vous essayez
et bien de réorganiser votre temps de
travail faire du travail en équipe pour
que on puisse être ouvert tous les jours
et avec un peu de flexibilité dans votre
temps de travail donc on comprend bien
que ça marche bien qu'on est dans une
grosse entreprise
ça y a aucun problème enfin il y a un
peu moins de problèmes parce que vous
avez beaucoup de de salariés vous pouvez
vous réorganiser beaucoup plus
facilement quand vous êtes très peu
nombreux bah oui ça nécessite bien sûr
et bien d'embaucher ou Ben et donc il y
a un coût supplémentaire donc une taille
critique quoi en quelque sorte plus vous
êtes grand et plus aussi vous êtes
capitalistique c'est-à-dire quand vous
avez des équipements ça ça marche bien
en général parce qu'on voit bien quand
vous êtes une grosse boîte industrielle
en fait souvent ça marche vous faites
travailler moins les hommes mais plus
les machines c'est la voix de machine le
travailler 7h par jour en fait vous
allez travailler mais allez un peu moins
longtemps mais les machines vont
travailler plus longtemps donc en fait
les gains de productivité c'est pas
forcément vos salariés qui vont vous les
apporter mais c'est votre machine qui va
qui va travailler plus longtemps donc là
on est au cœur de la question parce que
nous on se pose la question de la
généralisation c'est-à-dire est-ce que
on peut effectivement dans tous les
secteurs dans toutes les tailles
d'entreprises qui s'ouvrent répondez à
ça pierre là je crois que c'est
effectivement plus facile ça se fait en
quelques semaines une grande entreprise
avec 800 salariés chez Mamie Nova quand
vous avez tous les salariés de Mamie
Nova qui passent à 32 heures sans baisse
de salaire l'entreprise a une
exonération comme elle crée 125 emplois
elle elle rêve de payer les cotisations
chômage et c'est pas très compliqué à
organiser c'est vrai que c'est ce que
dit Eric s'il y a 800 salariés qui font
la même chose pour faire du yaourt c'est
plus facile mais quand je dis qu'il y a
déjà 400 entreprises qui sont passées à
4 jours c'est y compris des PME dans mon
coin des Pyrénées si vous allez acheter
du chocolatine ou une tarte aux fraises
à une boulangerie de peau ceux qui
feront le contrôle bactériologique à
biocé ils sont passés à 4 jours combien
de salariés j'ai pas inventé le dossier
c'est une la structure dans l'agence on
parlait tout à l'heure au maquillage de
l'agence verte qui est une agence de
publicité y compris les deux associés
les deux patrons vous les profiter des
quatre jours ça a été un peu le base
elles ont recruté il y a eu des
recrutements et elles sont restées
ouvertes à la clientèle 5 jours et au
début moi c'était le bazar mais c'est
tout à fait possible y compris dans les
petits trucs ça marche on est bien
d'accord quand il y a pas de baisse de
salaire tout à fait donc je le répète
plus lentement l'idée elle a été lancée
vous aurez vous en 93 par Antoine Ribou
parfois c'est interdit que c'est Michel
Rocard et moi où on a poussé mais celui
qui a eu le courage de lancer le débat
en septembre 93 c'est Antoine Riboud le
patron de Danone et qui dit il faut
passer à quatre jours 32 heures sans
étape intermédiaire il dit ça obligera
toutes les entreprises à créer des
emplois et Antoine Ribou avant de dire
ça avait fait travailler toutes ses
équipes dans toutes les filiales de
Danone dans tous les métiers pendant 6
mois pour vérifier que c'était possible
avec l'idée d'un financement à l'époque
c'est la sève d'été qui disait on met
des milliards pour compenser les
conséquences du chômage est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas activer une partie des
dépenses et dire quelque chose de très
simple si l'entreprise passe à 4 jours
32 heures de façon couple et créer des
emplois des vrais emplois en CDI elle
arrête de payer les cotisations chômage
donc ça c'était l'idée de départ on
obtenu une loi pour sa pas juste une
idée ça a été une loi la loi de Robien
en 95-96 et après ça on a eu 400
entreprises dans tous les secteurs tous
les détails d'activités avec des
créations d'emploi donc il y a aucun
stress les gens font une journée qui
n'est pas plus longue et il y a des
créations d'emploi donc c'est aussi plus
de gens qui cotisent les caisses de
retraite ça suppose je reviens vers vous
juste après Éric et hier que il y ait
une aide de l'État sinon ça fonctionne
pas alors si les gars si on reste au
même au même niveau de salaire
ça dépend ce que si vous n'arrivez pas à
faire les gains de productivité
suffisant pour maintenir le salaire de
vos salariés alors qu'il travaille moins
longtemps effectivement il faut bien que
quelqu'un paye et donc soit les
entreprises prennent sur leur marge soit
et ben elles vont demander des aides de
l'État donc ça c'est voilà bon on peut
penser que dans certains cas de figure
vous arrivez à dégager des gains de
productivité suffisants c'est là où dans
l'industrie vous faites travailler plus
les machines dans certains secteurs
peut-être ça va être dit mais le salarié
a fait des gains de productivité parce
qu'ils sont mieux il y a moins de burn
out il y a moins d'absence au travail et
donc du coup peut-être que les gains de
productivité qu'on pense mais si vous
avez compensé les gains de productivité
il y a pas de création d'emploi donc
vous voyez il faut il faut vraiment
savoir est-ce que vous faites ça pour
créer des emplois et auxquels ça veut
dire que les gains de productivité ne
sont pas compensées donc pour produire
la même chose il vous faut plus de
personnes il vous faut embaucher et donc
là il vous faut des aides voilà soit
vous dites maintenant en fait j'arrive à
le faire de la de la même façon et dans
ces cas là je n'ai pas besoin d'aide
mais je ne vais pas forcément embaucher
ou alors je vais embaucher parce que mes
salariés seront encore plus productives
je vais gagner des parts de marché sur
d'autres personnes mais macro est connu
pour vous faites pas de gain il y a un
terme que j'entends de plus en plus que
les entreprises bannissaient c'était
presque un tabou c'était de parler de la
santé mentale des des salariés et
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un thème qui
est assumé Marie Lacroix finalement
notre débat il rentre il rentre en plein
dans cette dans cette question là oui
tout à fait je pense que c'est aussi les
sœurs du numérique et de de la sur
sollicitation informationnelle qui a
porté cette question là de la santé
mentale on sent tous forcément que
parfois voilà travailler en débordement
c'est à dire en dehors de ces temps de
travail c'était connecté en permanence
ça questionne cette capacité à maintenir
un équilibre cognitif sur le long terme
effectivement ce que le week-end pardon
nous interrompre mais est-ce que le
week-end permet de de se pas ressourcer
et donc ça serait un argument en faveur
de la semaine de quatre choses c'est ce
qu'on appelle le besoin de récupération
donc en gros quand on est au travail en
fait on sollicite nos ressources
mentales et physiques pour répondre au
challenge voilà qui nous sont demandés
et en fait ça se traduit très très
concrètement par une augmentation par
exemple de l'hormone cortisol donc on a
on est dans cet état d'activation qui
nous permet de répondre à ces challenge
et en fait on sait que pour maintenir
cet état d'activation chaque jour il
faut des temps de récupération donc ça
c'est pas nouveau c'est pour ça que on a
limité le nombre d'heures dans une
journée de travail on sait très bien que
c'est pas qu'une question de ressource
physique cette fatigue physique il y a
aussi cette fatigue mentale on fait plus
d'erreurs on a plus voilà d'erreurs
d'attention si on maintient une
concentration
[Musique]
on était plutôt dans cette approche là
il fallait se répartir puisqu'on pour
faire baisser le chômage notamment
aujourd'hui je pense que à mes yeux ces
économies là on peut un peu moins la
cote c'est plus une théorie qui n'est
plus forcément d'actualité et j'ai
plutôt l'impression que la motivation
c'est la work life balance enfin le le
l'équilibre professionnel le sens qu'on
donne à notre travail leur place du
travail économique qui a été efficace ou
pas efficace on en reparlera j'ai
l'impression qu'on est maintenant sur un
raisonnement sociétal d'une certaine
manière et que la motivation est
différente et donc peut-être que avant
de penser la généralisation il faut voir
aussi à quoi ça répond d'une certaine
façon comme et puis avec une question de
timing aussi le chômage est au plus bas
je sais pas depuis 40 ans depuis 82 de
mémoire en tout cas les voilà les les
chiffres qui sont les plus communément
utilisés est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est le moment pour passer la semaine
de 4 jours je crois que c'est le bon
moment pour plein de raisons différentes
là encore vendredi c'est le commissaire
européen achat éducation sociale qui dit
c'est un plus pour recruter il y a plein
de l'autre jour j'entends déjà le patron
d'un restaurant qui dit il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ne veulent plus qu'on est
dans la restauration on finit à minuit à
une heure du mat à 2h du mat et si pour
le même salaire je peux proposer quatre
jours au lieu de 5 ils feront des
journées très longues mais il y a trois
jours ils seront pas au boulot donc il y
a des secteurs où c'est un plus pour
recruter il y en a d'autres c'est pour
l'équilibre mental ça reste il y a quand
même des crash en emploi il reste
toujours 2 minutes attention à la charge
mentale d'une journée plus longue c'est
non pardon justement
on voit qu'il y a que 20 salariés sur
300 qui sont d'accord pour des journées
plus longues je me bats on se bat pour
les 4 jours 32 heures en Allemagne
IgA métal demande les 32 heures sans
baisse de salaire en Espagne Pedro
Sanchez expérimente les 32 heures sans
base de salaire vous faites bien de le
préciser et quand Gabriel Attal propose
les 36 heures ben c'est un bide en
français ça s'appelle un bide les gens
ne veulent pas faire d'une journée plus
longue alors la question de la du
recrutement ça aussi c'est une question
centrale qui est au cœur de notre
ectomie avec de beaucoup de secteurs qui
peignent toujours à recruter et donc
l'argument de la semaine de quatre jours
bah ça peut être un bon argument pour
que pour rendre l'entreprise finalement
plus attractive écoutez cet ingénieur
embauché il y a un peu plus de deux mois
dans une entreprise qui s'appelle
radioshop la notion donc de rythme de
semaine des quatre jours on a été
présenté et c'est vrai que dans ma
position est dans un métier comme le
mien ou il y a quand même énormément de
possibilités et d'offres et surtout de
recruteurs qui viennent nous débaucher
tous les jours ça m'a fait grandement
réfléchir et c'est vrai que ça introduit
une notion nouvelle pour moi qui était
l'idée d'avoir du temps pour moi
réellement est-ce que c'est un argument
la semaine de 4 jours que que vos
clients finalement que les entreprises
que vous conseillez veulent de plus en
plus mettre en avant aujourd'hui face à
cette demande et voilà des futurs
salariés oui et puis on le voit
finalement ce qui a été présenté dans le
reportage du début avec cette idée que
le problème qui arrive c'est qu'on y a
pas de turn-over partir l'engagement est
présent et donc c'est effectivement
aussi la promesse salariée comment
est-ce qu'on attire les talents
la plupart des intéressés esquives ce
qui est intéressant c'est que à côté
négatif apparemment c'est qu'on arrive
plus à se débarrasser finalement tout le
monde reste alors que Macron
économiquement les entreprises nous
disent que leur gros problème
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'ils appellent la
grande démission la grande démission en
France c'est pas on veut plus travailler
c'est on ne reste pas et on démissionne
très vite de son CDI bah vous voyez donc
justement si vous voulez un tout petit
peu garder vos salariés ben c'est une
possibilité de le faire et le deuxième
point macroéconomie m'en parlant qui
pose problème aujourd'hui c'est les
arrêts de travail vous avez énormément
d'arrêt de travail vous voyez en gros
avant la covid les arrêts de travail
étaient incertain niveau pendant la
crise covid il montait très élevé et
donc ça c'est normal on était malade et
on pensait que une fois vacciné c'est
tôt aller redescendre non nous dignité
il reste très élevé quasiment au niveau
un peu mais nettement supérieur à la
situation qui valait avant la crise
sanitaire ben oui si vous arrivez avec
la semaine de 4 jours à diminuer les
arrêts maladie les burn out etc ça aussi
ça va un macroéconiquement dans le bon
sens parce que aujourd'hui la durée du
travail si elle est plus faible c'est
parce qu'il y a plus d'arrêt maladie
elle est comme promis on va comparer la
situation de la France à celle d'autres
pays européens mathiasa revenir sur ce
plateau rebonsoir Mathias rebonsoir
bienvenue à vous donc cette réflexion
sur la semaine de 4 jours ben elle n'est
pas propre à la France d'autres pays s'y
essayent déjà absolument il y a
différentes chapelles d'un côté ceux qui
passent à quatre jours sans réduire le
nombre d'heures comme la Belgique ou le
Royaume-Uni on va peut-être commencer
avec nos voisins du nord pour eux c'est
une loi de septembre 2022 qui prévoit la
possibilité d'effectuer son temps de
travail qui est aussi entre 38 et 40
heures en quatre jours donc avec deux
principes que ce soit un sur la base du
volontariat et deux pour une période de
test de six mois renouvelable outre
Manche tout part d'une expérimentation
lancée en juin 2022 pour 6 mois au
départ et dans une soixantaine
d'entreprises là aussi pas d'heure en
moins mais une compression du planning
sur quatre jours et début février les
résultats tombent 92% des organisations
sont satisfaites gain de productivité
pour certaines et une expérimentation
renouvelée et puis il y a les pays qui
en profitent pour réduire le temps de
travail comme l'a fait l'Espagne Thomas
est un projet lancé par le Premier
ministre socialiste pedrossancies en
2022 au total 200 PME volontaires vont
passer pendant trois ans à 32 heures
hebdomadaire en quatre jours contre 40
heures en 5 jours actuellement comme le
veut la loi le coût de l'opération est
pris en charge par des financements
publics l'objectif étant d'évaluer à
terme si la productivité des entreprises
à 32 heures est équivalente à celle de
40 heures pour éventuellement ensuite
pérenniser la mesure et puis on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure que dit la
Commission européenne alors elle pousse
en ce sens dans un entretien publié
jeudi dernier par l'agence de
presse-portugaise Louza le commissaire
européen à l'emploi Nicolas Schmitt
suggère d'expérimenter la semaine de
quatre jours dans des secteurs qui
rencontrent des difficultés à attirer
des employés le luxe le Luxembourgeois
l'affirme et je le cite de nombreux
secteurs désespérément des employés et
ne peuvent les trouver parce que les
gens ne veulent pas y travailler ils
doivent devenir plus attractifs est-ce
que c'est une solution à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre lui semble le croire pour
autant il prévient pour leur pas de
position commune au sein de l'Union
européenne sur la question merci Mathias
Marie Lacroix comme promis je reviens
vers vous quelle leçon vous tirer de
cette expérimentation anglaise tiens
pour vous et d'ailleurs peut-être là il
a été précisé que dans cette
expérimentation il y avait pas de
réduction du temps de travail or
vraiment l'expérimentation c'est du 180
100 le principe c'était ça ça veut dire
100% des objectifs enfin de la
productivité 80% de temps travaillé et
100% des salaires donc c'était ça
l'engagement et donc tous les
entreprises qui ont participé ont eu
montré qu'ils avaient fait effectivement
une réduction significative du temps de
travail donc il y a quand même cette
réduction qui est pris d'accord une
réduction du temps de travail et sur
cette question là de la généralisation
ce qui est intéressant donc dans cette
expérimentation c'est que tous les types
d'entreprises ont été
en tout cas il y a beaucoup de
des entreprises de secteurs et de taille
variées il y a beaucoup d'entreprises de
moins de 10 personnes qui ont participé
donc c'est possible aussi à une taille
réduite et sur les secteurs il y a
effectivement des secteurs de services
on voit effectivement qu'on peut
peut-être augmenter la productivité mais
il y a aussi des secteurs industriels du
BTP etc qui ont participé à
l'expérimentation et donc effectivement
les résultats sont très positifs
donc là les résultats ont été donnés en
début d'année 2023 et effectivement
l'envie de maintenir le rythme de la
semaine de quatre jours et présent dans
la grande majorité des entreprises on a
que 5% qui ont mis une expérimentation
en pause effectivement c'est ce qu'on
disait ce qui est disait Mathias 9
entreprises sur 10 qui se disent à 17
pierre là vous avez d'autres chiffres
liés
notamment sur les vous évoquez les la
question des arrêts de travail de sur la
santé au travail il y a eu il y a eu un
impact positif que le risque de burn out
a vraiment reculé que l'absentéisme a
reculé je peux vous parler de la
Belgique la Belgique j'arrive de
Bruxelles à l'âge du train et j'y
retourne ce soir quand on me demande aux
gens de faire une journée plus longue il
y a quasiment aucune entreprise il y a
une loi qui a été négociée d'Anne
coalition compliquée qui proposait la
semaine de quatre jours compacté et la
plupart des gens disent mais non ça ne
m'intéresse pas si on veut c'est les 4
jours 32 heures donc le débat est le
même en Belgique et par contre dans les
entreprises qui en Angleterre le bilan
excellente et je reviens dans les
entreprises qui est utilisé le loi de
Robien c'est pareil le médecin du
travail est fait le bilan chez Mamie
Nova au bout de deux ans et on voit que
l'atlantisme recule et qu'on a enrichi
le travail quelque chose qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que il y a un
jour par semaine le contremaître le
directeur de l'usine la directrice
générale sont aussi à 4 jours donc un
jour par semaine ou le patron n'est pas
là et aussi le client appelle il faut
que les salariés puissent répondre donc
il y avait eu un plan de coin
investissement formation qui fait qu'on
avait les gens travaillaient moins ils
passaient vraiment à quatre jours mais
en plus pour beaucoup le travail était
plus intéressant ce qui fait que du coup
ils sont encore moins absents ils ont du
temps pour eux pour leur vie perso un
autre exemple que j'ai envie de citer
c'est une imprimerie qui était passée à
4 jours et il y a un blocage la première
artésienne et au bout d'un an je vais
faire le bilan et le patron me dit vas-y
mais il y en a deux qui vont t'engueuler
il y a eu un référendum il y en a que
deux qui avaient voté contre parce qu'il
y a vu un petit blocage de salaire ils
étaient en train d'acheter leur maison
donc ils vont t'engueuler à cause du
blocage donc j'y vais et je m'attends à
me faire engueuler par un des ouvriers
et en fait il me dit les quatre jours
c'est génial il y a une fois par semaine
je vais à la piscine avec mon fils on va
à la piscine ensemble on va la pizzeria
et ça tout changé donc ce monsieur était
censé m'engueuler parce que à cause de
moi à cause des quatre jours il avait eu
son célèbre bloqué pendant un an et en
fait il disait juste en terme de qualité
de vie ça change tout dans les relations
personnelles et pourtant le patronat
français aujourd'hui il est réticent je
vous propose d'écouter Geoffroy route
des yeux et d'analyser pourquoi ces
réticences juste après semaine de 4
jours je pense que c'est une illusion
malheureusement
nous on est conscient que dans les
entreprises la césure entre ceux qui
peuvent télétravailler et pas
télétravailler est un problème il faut
réfléchir à aux compensations qu'on peut
offrir mais demander aux gens de faire
35 heures sur 4 jours je pense que c'est
risqué des
toutes sortes de problèmes divin soit
étant dit rien n'empêche une entreprise
aujourd'hui de faire la semaine de
quatre jours donc il y a pas de
négociation à mettre la loi n'interdit
pas s'il y a un accord de le faire alors
on va débattre autour de cette
déclaration de Béziers je vais vous
redonner la parole mériter c'est
intéressant parce que là il dit demander
aux gens de faire 35 heures sur 4 jours
donc on n'est pas sur une baisse du
temps de travail je pense que c'est
risqué toutes sortes de problèmes mais
est-ce que tout le monde pourra passer à
32 heures à salaire égal C'est ça la
vraie question non mais effectivement
travailler 9 heures par jour c'est pas
une bonne idée ça ça a été dit donc ok
donc effectivement faire 35 heures en
quatre jours c'est pas forcément une
bonne idée sauf qu'il y a des
entreprises qui pourront peut-être pas
faire autrement mais voilà donc du coup
le problème et je comprends que le
patronat soit un peu chaque fois c'est
que ça pose une énorme équation pour le
manager c'est-à-dire qu'il faut vraiment
réfléchir à la réorganisation de sa
production de son de façon très et donc
c'est bien aux managers une nouvelle
équation lui dire voilà il va falloir
que tu arrives à faire travailler tes
salariés que 32 heures par semaine en 4
jours tous ensemble c'est à dire que
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas faire à la carte certains vont faire
4 jours dont on va faire 5 jours c'est
que généralement c'est l'entreprise et
donc oui bien sûr c'est au manager à
réfléchir à tout cela et donc c'est pour
ça que pour l'instant il me semble quand
même que les entreprises qui le font
c'est sous le le et elles sont
volontaires et donc bien sûr quand vous
êtes volontaire c'est que vous avez déjà
réfléchi et vous voyez que dans ce cas
de figure là c'est bénéfique mais ouais
peut-être que si vous devez les
généraliser à tout le monde il est
possible certaines entreprises et vous
voyez ça c'est vu avec les 35 heures
quand vous êtes hostile à la mesure vous
allez pas bien réfléchir à la façon de
faire et donc effectivement ça va être
une catastrophe donc il faudrait le voir
positivement et c'est là où les salariés
peuvent jouer leur rôle en disant si tu
veux que je viens dans ton entreprise il
va falloir que tu réfléchisses un mot
rapide il y a quand même une question
c'est si l'entreprise passe à 32 heures
donc on a dit les journées plus longues
c'est pas la bonne idée on a bien
compris et si on veut créer des emplois
il faut qu'il y ait une aide on avait
obtenu en 96 de dire ça n'est pas
obligatoire on avait été aussi la
baisser la durée légale mais dire si une
entreprise les salariés les patrons se
mettent d'accord pour la 32 heures avec
des créations d'emploi ce serait normal
de mettre l'argent sur la table qui le
fasse dans des bonnes conditions donc si
vous allez sur le site semaine de 4
jours.fr semaine de 4 jours.fr on ne
lance un appel pour demander qui est de
nouveau une loi qui rentre possible et
32 heures sans base de salaire si ceux
et celles qui nous écoutent veulent
passer dans leur entreprise à 30 km
du secteur privé qui sont passés à 32
heures sans bal de salaire patient avait
ça et qui ont créé des emplois vous ne
l'avez dit déjà mais et on va se poser
la question effectivement du parallèle
que vous faisiez avec les 35 heures
Mathieu va va revenir là-dessus mais je
voudrais quand même vous entendre sur
sur cette question de la généralisation
et peut-être de l'expérimentation c'est
un mot qu'on a déjà employé dans dans ce
débat mais sur lequel je pense il faut
insister
peut-être qu'il faut expérimenter
différentes formules de semaine de 4
jours en fonction des secteurs en
fonction des tailles d'entreprise avant
de se décider c'est ça il y a pas une
semaine de quatre jours finalement il y
a plusieurs semaines de quatre jours et
justement l'expérimentation au
Royaume-Uni a vraiment fait sa
c'est-à-dire comment est-ce qu'on
propose notre semaine de 4 jours en tant
qu'entreprise à nos salariés comment on
réfléchit ensemble et donc tous les
entreprises ont eu deux mois
d'accompagnement à travers des ateliers
pour réfléchir ensemble à quelle est
l'organisation du travail qu'on veut
proposer demain avec la semaine de
quatre jours et donc ça justement les
impacts qui sont à toutes les échelles
c'est pas que une échelle individuelle
en tant qu’équilibre pro perso c'est pas
que là où ça se joue il y a l'individuel
il y a le collectif moi en tant que
manager comment je gère mon équipe qui
est à 4 jours oui les interactions
sociales au sein de l'entreprise c'est
aussi des impacts que ça peut avoir les
interactions sociales comme finalement
si tout le monde est à 4 jours et pas
sur les mêmes jours on se voit que trois
jours que c'est quoi les temps
collectifs qu'est-ce qui reste du
collectif de travail comment on
maintient ce capital social c'est
ressources là dont on a besoin pour se
soutenir se faire confiance agir
ensemble etc donc tout ça c'est question
elle se posent et c'est intéressant de
se dire en tant qu'entreprise quel est
le modèle que j'ai envie d'avoir c'est
quoi mon modèle de la semaine de 4 jours
et comment je me réorganise en interne
pour que ça soit possible donc notamment
justement quels sont les activités que
finalement j'accepte de réduire est-ce
que les temps de réunion sont réduits
quelle réunions j'accepte de faire
sauter peut-être est-ce que finalement
les temps de pause comment je peux
maintenir finalement une productivité en
maintenant quand même c'est en de pause
et c'est tant d'interaction informelle
au quotidien donc toutes ces questions
elles se posent et elles finalement
elles bénéficie au-delà de la semaine de
quatre jours tout le monde a gagné à y
gagner à se poser ce type de questions
en fait sur vraiment l'organisation du
travail et comment voilà on fait
circuler l'information comment on traite
voilà les réunions au quotidien etc donc
des bas de société qui sont de la
réduction du temps de travail forcément
il faut jeter un coup d'œil dans le
rétroviseur Mathieu
les 35 heures alors déjà en se disant
que aucun gouvernement c'est vraiment
penché sur la réduction du temps de
travail depuis les 35 heures parce que
deux décennies après leur adoption et 35
heures restent à la fois un totem et un
tabou si j'ose dire la gauche qui se
plairait voir cette mesure inscrite au
fronton des grandes conquêtes sociales
on est pour ses frais ça n'a pas été le
cas et quand à droite qui n'a cessé de
les vilipender les 35 heures en disant
qu'il fallait les abroger là j'ai jamais
été le faire alors il faut dire que
l'histoire avait commencé comme une
plaisanterie quand même vous en souvenez
elle est connue mais on l'a rappelé tout
ça sur un coin de table dans un
restaurant La légende raconte que ce fut
même griffonner sur une nappe en papier
c'était Dominique soscane qui était
responsable du programme économique du
Parti socialiste qui un jour où il
cherchait en 1997 des idées de gauche a
commencé à dire pourquoi pas les emplois
jeunes pourquoi pas les 35 heures et
tous ces convives parmi lesquels
Jean-Christophe comédie Jean-Marie legen
un certain modèle Val sont applaudis en
disant c'est génial comme idée sauf que
Jacques Chirac a 10 ou assemblée que la
gauche a gagné quasi par surprise et que
Lionel qui est un homme qui disait ce
qu'il faisait et ce qu'il faisait ce
qu'il disait c'est dit ben on a promis
ça maintenant il faut le faire il se
trouve que c'est cette pilule
empoisonnée est tombée chez Martine
aubryck et même n'était pas du tout
convaincu de la faire elle était plutôt
pour laisser les choses se faire la
réduction de son travail au fil du
siècle mais pas forcément légiférer mais
en bon soldat c'est elle qui s'y est
collé et avec la mère forte s'il vous
plaît d'abord une loi d'expérimentation
vous en souvenez puis une loi de
générisation donc tout ça résonne quand
même encore aujourd'hui et donc la seule
loi de généralisation a mis tous les
salariés de toutes les entreprises de
France aux nouvelles horaires
emballé c'était pesé avec quel résultat
mais pour le moins mitigé sur le plan
social d'abord parce que les 35 heures
ont fait apparaître toute une toute une
ribambelle d'inégalité alors bien sûr
les cadres ont découvert les joies des
demi-journées le RTT mais pour beaucoup
d'ouvriers avec la modulation ce qu'on
appelait ou l'analysation du temps de
travail elle est 35 heures sont trouvés
avec plus de flexibilité ou en tout cas
des horaires à géométrie variable j'ai
des inégalités entre le salarié les
petits structures et des grosses
structures c'est vrai que c'est plus
commode quand on est dans une grosse
entreprise de le faire sur le plan
économique ensuite impossible d'y voir
clair je parle sous le contrôle sur le
nombre sur le nombre d'enfants du nombre
de varient selon les rapports la pire
estimation que j'ai trouvée c'était
15000 à peu près la plus belle d'une
certaine façon c'était 350 000
emplois créés ou préserver et mais quand
même tous s'accorder à dire aussi que
c'était la croissance de l'époque qui
était assez belle il faut le dire qu'il
y avait aussi le joueur et puis alors
sur le plan politique pour le coup là
c'est la cata à l'élection
présidentielle suivante vous souvenez
qu'en 2002 et ben les Français c'est on
conjugué Lionel Jospin dès le premier
tour pire et les 35 heures ont même
servir d'épouvantail préféré à la droite
qui va les rendre responsables de tous
les mots la compétitivité le chômage la
baisse de croissance et puis ça va
coller aux socialistes comme le sport là
du capitaine Haddock donc du coup ils ne
sont ventrons vraiment jamais et
pourtant personne ne les a vraiment
abrogé oui parce que de la souplesse a
été rendu aux entreprises depuis elle
est contingents heures supplémentaires
ont été prosibles augmenté les heures
sup elle-même ensuite ont été encouragés
sous les travailler plus pour gagner
plus tout ça a été défiscalisé ça encore
été le cas récemment mais personne ça il
faut le dire n'est revenu sur l'horaire
légal de la semaine de travail parce que
beaucoup d'entreprises qui avaient gagné
en contrepartie des baisses de charges
on l'a dit puis de la flexibilité était
pas demandeuse et puis les Français
quand on les interroge sur les sondages
s'ils sont aussi habitués comme quoi les
35 heures même dans les douleurs on
finit par s'installer
peut-être sur les chiffres emploi créés
est-ce que oui pourquoi pourquoi
donner non mais il y a des simulations
qui avaient été faites énormément
d'écart et après il y a des évaluations
explosent
celle qu'il faut prendre me semble-t-il
c'est celle l'officiel c'est celle
réalisée par l'Insee et la DG trésor
d'accord et à l'époque signé par le
Premier ministre qui s'appelait Fillon
qui était pas pro 35 heures et c'est
celle-ci qui évalue à 350000 emplois qui
sont pas liés à la croissance économique
etc donc c'est plus 350 000 emplois bon
voilà c'est un bilan effectivement qui
peut paraître léger quand on était avec
les 2 millions de certaines simulations
mais parce qu'il faut dire que ce qui
était mis en place c'est pas du tout la
réduction du temps de travail que
certains espéraient à l'époque c'est à
dire que c'était très conditionné ça a
été dit c'est-à-dire que en contrepartie
vous voyez là où je suis peut-être que
j'aurai un bémol c'est que je trouve que
Martine Aubry a pas été dur là-dessus
elle est arrivée en 97 d'accord la loi
c'est 35 heures c'était en 2000 donc
pendant deux ans et demi les entreprises
et ça c'était pour les plus de vins et
pour les moins de 20 c'est 2002 donc
vous rendez compte il y a la laisser
énormément de temps aux entreprise pour
négocier avec avec leurs salariés 2002
ils perdent l'élection donc normalement
c'était facile de complètement l'abroger
ça va être fait parce qu'effectivement
les entreprises ont énormément gagné
notamment avec l'annualisation du temps
de travail qui est effectivement et tu
peut-être une catastrophe pour les
ouvriers parce qu'ils perdent énormément
en heures supplémentaires et donc
effectivement pour eux ils pouvaient ils
préfèrent sans doute travailler plus que
et gagner plus que que finalement
travailler moins gagné moi Pierre
effectivement ce que dit Mathieu c'est
devenu un totem ou un tabou ça ça
finalement avec le recul est-ce que ça
va pas tous ces tous c'est un peu figé
on a un peu cette impression là tu es le
débat dans tous les pays d'Europe vous
avez jusque là tous les pays non mais
c'est clair il y a 6 ans le patron de
tous les syndicats belges je voulais
relancer la semaine de 4 jours il me
faisait venir tous les 6 mois à
Bruxelles et il y a une fois il m'a dit
en me raccompagne dans la gagne mais du
coup ça a été le grand combat de toutes
les forces de progrès depuis un siècle
on est passé de 16 jours à 6 on est
passé de 6 jours à 5 on a eu les congés
payés voilà c'était le grand combat
alors qu'il y avait pas tellement de
gain de productivité et depuis les 35
ans n'ose plus en parler c'est devenu le
sujet tabou parce que ce Mathieu est
vrai mais il y a en plus eu les 35
heures à l'hôpital c'est un énorme bazar
parce que le ministère des Finances ne
voulait pas créer des postes on a été
très nombreux à dire attendez vous avez
promis les 35 heures au personnel
soignants donc si vous plaît ouvrir les
écoles d'infirmière et d'infirmiers 3
ans avant on avait des très nombreux et
non pas du tout le ministère des
Finances vous voulez faire des économies
de façon scandaleuse on doit ils auront
droit le RTT mais on verra comment donc
évidemment c'est un énorme bazar et donc
la droite qui ne demandait que ça on a
profité pour tuer les 35 heures et
maintenant on voit bien que le débat
revient y compris des gens de droite
même à Davos à Davos il y avait un débat
sur la semaine de quatre jours en
février il y avait le ministre
néerlandaise qui est une femme de droit
du travail et qui a dit aujourd'hui au
Pays-Bas la durée moyenne est à 29
heures par semaine aujourd'hui au
heures mais c'est la plupart des femmes
qui font trois jours par semaine et la
plupart des hommes qui sont à 5 jours et
donc même la ministre de droite disait
ce serait peut-être mieux que homme et
femme on soit tous à 4 jours que homme
et femme en a un vrai boulot et un vrai
revenu et que homme et femme on ait du
temps libre donc y compris il y a
vraiment je pense que le covid a fait
bouger les mentalités et que ce serait
dommage qu'on rate qu'on n'est pas un
vrai débat cette fois-ci en France
est-ce que effectivement je rebondis ce
que vous venez de dire on est inégaux
face à la semaine de quatre jours en
fonction de de son genre homme femme
seule avec enfant par exemple j'imagine
que quand on parlait d'expérimentation
et de variétés les situations ça rentre
dans la démonstration
oui tout à fait en fait
quelle est la trait de la semaine de 4
jours mais même en 4 jours à la CNAV
finalement les personnes qui ont accepté
cette expérimentation il y a des
personnes qui étaient déjà finalement à
quatre jours pour des contraintes
familiales et qui ont accepté enfin de
de d'augmenter un peu leur journée pour
avoir une augmentation de salaire par
exemple donc finalement c'est un peu
retrouver un salaire qui parce que la
réalité c'est que les temps partiels
sont souvent
occupés par des femmes et donc
finalement c'est une manière de aller
vers un peu plus d'égalité salariale
dans les faits quoi
donc ça ça a été une des motivations
pour une des personnes concernées alors
je vous propose un dernier témoignage on
l'a entendu dans les dans les titres
c'est un chef d'entreprise qui qui parle
de la l'efficacité la de ces salariés en
semaine de quatre jours sur l'entreprise
elle s'appelle pro cima lui il est ultra
positif on l'écoute je dirais que du
positif on a moins de stress ils sont
très motivés ils sont plus efficaces
mais réellement je le ressens dans les
dans les dans les process dans tout le
process de mise en place des
chez les clients c'est vraiment vraiment
très positif et surtout je les vois
sourire je les vois je les vois heureux
vraiment je les je dis pas qu'ils
étaient pas heureux avant mais je les
vois vraiment vraiment épanouie
est-ce que un salarié qui passe à alors
je suis précis la semaine de quatre
jours mais 32 heures même salaire est-ce
qu'il va forcément être plus rentable
enfin plus efficace pas plus rentable
plus
mais sa productivité sur la semaine
c'est pas évident ça vous voyez ça
serait ça serait trop simple sinon il y
aurait pas de création d'emplois encore
une fois si on le fait c'est qu'on la
productivité horaire le gain ne compense
pas le fait qu'on travaille moins
d'heures et que donc moins de jours
aussi et donc normalement la
productivité du salarié en globalité
baisse un peu c'est ça qui oblige
quelque part ou qui permet les créations
d'emploi sinon il y en aurait pas donc
mais c'est encore une fois là où on est
en train de se poser c'est on est dans
un moment très particulier où le sens au
travail est extrêmement important et
donc si on veut en plus que les gens
travaillent plus longtemps et qu'à 60
ans 62 ans 63 ans 11 soit encore motivé
ça c'est ce type de mesure qui permet
d'arriver à 62 ans beaucoup plus motivé
que si on n'était pas passé au 5 jours
et donc il faut voir ça tout au long de
sa vie et là je pense que la
productivité tout au long de sa vie il
gagne lorsqu'on arrive à bien et bien
décidé de faire une bonne répartition au
temps de travail et loisirs dernier mot
pour vous pierre là où tu es où sur le
est-ce que c'est pas le sens de
l'histoire avec on a fait un déjà sur
l'intelligence artificielle ici sur
l'impact de l'intangé dans artificielle
sur nos emplois enfin voilà une belle
économie qui vient de dire que j'ai pété
il faut passer à 4 jours si on veut
éviter non mais sans rien Nicolas
Schmitt le site le commissaire européen
le site et il m'en a parlé on est
ensemble à Berlin la réponse est oui
mais alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire mais c'est pour faire une société
avec son travail mais deux mois non
justement ce n'est pas la fin du travail
ceux et celles qui vont 4 jours par
semaine au boulot ils sont très
impliqués l'absenté ils sont très
contents d'avoir en même temps la
plupart d'entre nous on veut un nouvel
équilibre en même temps un vrai boulot
un vrai boulot intéressant et un vrai
salaire et avoir du temps pour vivre on
a eu le week-end de Pentecôte la plupart
d'entre nous on a pris trois jours c'est
très agréable mais ça nous empêche pas
de bosser vraiment les quatre jours de
la semaine et donc je pense c'est cet
équilibre donc raison de plus j'insiste
dernier en 96 on avait obtenu à la Juppé
ne voulait pas mais il avait accepté une
loi qui donnait des aides aux
entreprises pour qu'elles passent à 32
heures sans baisse de salaire dans des
bonnes conditions et des créations
d'emplois donc je pense qu'il faut dans
les mois qui viennent qu'on arrive à
obtenir de nouveaux cette loi vous allez
sur le site semaine de quatre jours
excusez-moi c'est tout à fait
on est un gouvernement qui est un peu
bloqué ça vous a pas échappé il faut
qu'on arrive à se débat le message est
passé par semaine de 4 jours.fr merci
beaucoup Lenny 4 fois dans l'émission
Gérard me laisser analytité faire autant
de choses merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat vous savez nos émissions sont
avoir et revoir avec la pub à
l'intérieur en replay sur public
sénat.fr c'est notre plateforme elle
vient d'être fondée et elle est super de
main dans la matinale c'est Franck
Riester le ministre délégué auprès de la
première ministre chargé des Relations
avec le Parlement eu beaucoup
d'actualité à l'Assemblée nationale
notamment aujourd'hui salut
[Musique]